good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everybody's having a great day it's a
Tuesday that for us not to brag feels
like a Friday this is our last show of
the week before we head into the
Thanksgiving weekend which is very
exciting hey J how you do I'm ding good
it's it's a Tuesday feels like a
Thursday cuz we still have a lot of work
to do before we can really enjoy the
holidays it's true it's true so while
this is our last official show of the
week there's much to be done there's
much to do over at our patreon
patreon.com theeast is where you can go
this holiday if you're missing y girls
yes we will be dropping episodes for the
rest of the week on patreon to make sure
everybody is well taken care of because
the holidays can be difficult but one
thing making the holidays less difficult
is our holiday merch drop so yesterday
we launched our wench sets on shop toast
merch.com the shop will be open for a
little bit longer want to make sure
everybody can get their orders in
whatever size they want it's all for
pre-order but we will close the shop
soon to ensure that that we can start
production and get everybody shipped out
as soon as possible so make sure to head
to shop toast merch.com as Jackie said
yesterday you don't have to rush but
make haste if you will yeah like do it
in a timely fashion we don't have
forever we don't I
mean the limit does
exist do you want to hear something
crazy always it very there's like a
small chance that it snows today and you
will see the snow and I have to say it
does feel bittersweet cuz if I do the
snow before Christmas in my apartment
like I will be so I will feel warmth and
I will feel Joy but it wouldn't feel
right experiencing it without Theo yeah
because Theo is still in the hospital
yes he's not home yet he probably won't
be for like I would I'm just guessing
the rest of the week you think he'll
spend Thanksgiving there I
do which sucks balls yeah I don't really
have an update for anyone today is like
a big day the truckers for Theo are
outside the outpouring of love I just
want to say the outpouring of love for
Theo I was reading the comments and of
course the truckers as well with their
horns like did you see all of that there
was so much love and prayers for him so
part of the reason why I was going to
like I almost didn't talk about it on
the toes but part of the reason that I
did is like when I spoke about Theo's
heart murmur so many people were like my
Cavalier my dog has a heart murmur like
he's fine so I just was like really
hoping for that sort of feedback and
people being like Oh my God I
experienced the same thing my dog had a
tumor on his throat my dog had a tumor
on his liver and hearing those sorts of
positive stories like that's really why
I I I spoke about it so I could read
that feedback so I did go searching for
those types of comments and like I just
want to say someone being like same
thing happened to my dog literally died
a week later you're not helpful and you
need to stop sorry that happened to you
but do not share that with me right I
meant just the love for the do aside
from you know personal testimonies and
using like the like um getting medical
information which is also always helpful
that that's how I felt about my circlage
uh but there's so much love for do
so much love for du from the toast
Community but also like people in my
life like every I had like my phone was
blowing up yesterday just people being
like Oh my God Theo what can I do so you
know you really realize how many
wonderful people you have in your life
that's always like a very small Silver
Line in situations like this how many
people Theo has touched like he is
literally a Cornerstone of the show the
show is as old as he is no 100 we
started the breath like 6 months before
you got Theo and then we started the
toast like six months after he is the
show he is the show he has a big day
today he has a CAT scan and a biopsy and
I'll know a lot more tonight and then
we'll figure it out I was going to make
a little joke that the dog is getting a
CAT scan yeah it would be funny if Theo
was a dog you know it would be that
would be funny that's why I didn't make
the joke but he's not because it's not
funny when it's true when it's you're it
I'm so glad we're on the same page there
my I've had an eye twitch for a week you
know when like your eye inv voluntarily
like just moves yeah but no one can see
it so you sound crazy crazy it is
bothering the [__] out of me maybe close
your eyes don't give them opportunity
I've been thinking about maybe securing
an eye patch like if I wear it for like
24 to 48 hours maybe it'll stop maybe
but I also feel like you just want to
wear an eye patch I definitely like I I
see the content that comes with an eye
patch and I'm definitely excited by that
yo ho yo ho a tur's life for
me
Jackie how are you doing I'm doing well
and I'm glad to see that you are doing
well and that you found you
know something your spirits seem well
given the situation and that's that's
all we can hope for at the moment I'm
trying yesterday was like the worst day
like literally canceled my whole whole
day laid in bed took a bath did nothing
and then I had this dinner party that
like honestly I was just dreading I did
not want to leave the house I was in
such a bad mood and as we were leaving
I'm like oh why did I agree to this and
when I got back in the car after I was
so glad that I went I had such a nice
time it was like a Jewish dinner party
with just like a bunch of different
Jewish celebs influencers like media
people and it was just like such good
food kosher food we had brisket it was
actually like one of those uplifting um
buoying buoying and just a really a
fabulous night and then I came home and
watched the second half of the Kansas
Philly game and that was fabulous too so
things are you know I don't have any
info on Theo you know in terms of
turning around but my spirit I feel like
whatever I put out will affect the
outcome of the results and like I need
to be putting out positive energy you
need to be
manifesting no I need to be putting out
positive energy okay I mean I agree with
you I didn't get to watch the game
because I couldn't get my TV on in my
bedroom and I was too lazy to fix it so
I just kept texting Zach for updates
where I would walk out for a snack and
find out who's winning you know you
could like Google it too my
TV no I mean you could Google how to
that but you could also just Google the
score yeah but it's just like a waste of
thumb movements and at the end but you
were texting Zach anyway no but like we
were just we talk you know right and I
was going for my snack so it it worked
out the Eagles won I'm happy for them it
was a crazy game because they didn't
really have any sort of lead until the
very very end and it was like they got
their [__] together at the end right as
like Patty and the team were just like
kind of stinking it up and it was like a
bad game for Travis Kelce which he
really doesn't have but he turned over
the ball he fumbled like a few times
I mean his girls going through it yeah
maybe they're just like connected
energy-wise and when one of them is you
know kind of like Z Zaden and violet
like when one of them is down the other
one carries that with them yeah which is
you know
beautiful poetically but not really for
career-wise I obviously like was
enjoying the game I wasn't particularly
rooting for anyone if I was I think I if
I had to think about it hard enough I
would have been rooting for the Eagles
cuz I don't know why I just feel like
everything happens for the Kansas City
Chiefs like so easily do you know what I
mean like they're just like always
winning I just feel like it's not even
hard for them yeah I'm happy that the
Eagles had their shine no offense during
an irrelevant game like where was thisg
in February Jackie got [__] roasted
to filth in the comments yesterday like
she was wrong we know that but calm down
I think I have to issue like a
disclaimer about when we talk about
sports and that doesn't and what you're
about to say doesn't mean we're going to
stop talking about sports cuz we're
learning talking about sports but I
guess I we're listening and we're
learning I guess I have to say and
because it wasn't clear we are not
Sports Experts we have really a very
limited idea of what's going on at any
given time we're very new to all of this
and we're learning as we go yet even as
we learn things we forget them and we
still make mistakes and we don't and we
don't know them for the next time we
don't know how all this works and
honestly they make it confusing for a
reason they don't want you to know so
true so yeah the game technically wasn't
irrelevant and thirsty but it felt that
way and but it's been on the schedule
like since day one yes it's been on the
schedule since last year so it wasn't
thirsty for Taylor but I also wanted to
clarify like it felt thirsty for Kelsey
Bowl because the last Super Bowl like I
didn't see you know a Bengals Rams match
up nobody gives a [__] like people care
about Kelsey Bowl so they're
capitalizing on the Brethren and that's
all I was saying and when I I was
watching adjacent to Zach last night and
I was like tell me about this game like
is it a little thirsty that the NFL put
it on like is it something that would
have happened first of all he starts
trying to
explain the NFC West AFC Claudia wish I
wish I could have recorded it because
I've never heard him more like not only
is it confusing inherently he did a bad
job explaining
it so I left even more confused but he
did say yeah it's a little bit you know
they're trying convenient convenient
yeah yeah so I just need to everyone to
calm down like it's so funny when you
like poke a certain community and you
don't realize like that's what happened
to me when I said that the and I stand
by what I said the bear was a bad show
you don't respect waiters like oh my God
calm down I just said it was a bad show
no I saw comment that was like you know
roasting going so hard like rude to me
for not getting this football thing
right and call the yif Thirsty I would
literally think it was Roger Goodell
writing in yeah no who else has that
much of a personal stake in me shading
the NFL no that's the thing like that's
the very interesting part of this job
when we talk about a wide breath of yeah
of things sometimes you'll find a
community you didn't even know existed
that's extremely
passionate yeah you you need to C down
yeah in the words of Taylor
Swift also I got to thinking last night
when I was watching the game because I
feel like you know there are a lot of
famous football players who are like
famous in culture and most of them are
the quarterbacks it's just like a a
position that's ripe with Fame and I was
comparing Patrick Mahomes to Jaylen Herz
who is the Eagles quarterback yeah and
it got me thinking like why jayen Herz
isn't more culturally famous like his
team was in the Super Bowl his team is
amazing they've been very good for a
very long time he's very handsome young
thing and then I was comparing him to
Patrick Mahomes who's like in a skims ad
and you know I just find like why why
isn't he more famous and not outside of
football I I don't have the answer but
if I might theorize which I'm sure
everyone will then hand my ass to me
again uh first of all how long has he
been the quarterback I feel like at
least like three
years that's not like a a really long
time but also I think being a
quarterback is inherently you know
you're in the spotlight but I think you
can also choose how much you want to do
outside of football like right Patrick
mahes I think he likes the fame and he
wants to do ad campaigns and he's like a
silly goofy personality guy and like
wants to put himself out there but I
don't think that's for everyone it is
his third season with the Eagles and
like they've been good for three seasons
you know and they've always been good
but like but I also feel like aside from
Jason Kelce I don't know many I don't
know the names of any Eagles players I
feel like they're more of a team and
less of like a oneman show I actually
know quite a few I'm familiar with Lane
Johnson I'm familiar with Rick Lavado
and that's because their wives are
toasters so I understand that that's you
know like a me thing yeah I was also
going to say oh another thing I was
wrong about I really felt last night
like the chiefs were going to win this
and then there would be a Super Bowl
Chiefs Eagles matchup and then the
Eagles would win right that's a good
theory but it didn't come to fruition
because they won last night but I was
also really happy that they won one
because I said like I just feel like
sometimes everything is so easy for the
Chiefs like I'd like to see like
somebody work for it and that was nice
but also J Kelce was 0 and3 going into
this game against his brother he has
never beat his brother and you know he's
the older brother and I feel like he's
you know often overlooked because Travis
is Travis so for him to have gotten you
know a win I'm happy for him what's so
funny though is in their family dynamic
in the way that Travis sees it he's
always trying to catch up to Jason yeah
well they play different positions so
you can't really like evenly compare
them no but his whole life like Jason
played football so he played football
Jason did this and I think there was
like some Scandal when they were
college and like I think Travis always
feels like he's in Jason Shadow but the
way that we know them it's like Travis
first yeah so I was not happy that Jason
got like a moment and I Ben was like we
could turn it off I'm like no I need to
see the brothers hug on the field like
the game isn't over yet and Jason was
like so happy was like Miz wasn't
Irrelevant in terms of like counting
towards their overall Seasons but
like it's I just I wish they won like a
Super Bowl sort of game like this to me
I know it's not but like it still feels
like a scrimmage like it's not the game
so now the Eagles are 9 and one they've
only lost once and do you know who they
lost
to the
49ers j e t s they lost to the Jets they
lost to the worst team in the league
which is so interesting and the Chiefs
are now seven and
three yikes
yikes cuz like I don't know why I just
if I had to just like say which team I
thought was better like I would say the
Chiefs maybe they just get more hype
yeah and we just are watching their
games yeah so I was happy for the Eagles
girlies the EES yeah happy and it was
very interesting for them and then this
is Thanksgiving weekend so apparently
there's some big matchups you know some
ag- old rivalries like the lions are
playing someone I'm not like really
familiar with that matchup me neither
but I know the Cowboys play every
Thanksgiving Thursday I don't know who
they're playing but Dolly Parton is the
halftime show oh Jack harlo is the
halftime show I saw it on TV um for
Thanksgiving as well probably like a
different game game yeah um okay here
are the the here is the lineup Packers
Lions apparently an age-old beef very
Midwest the commanders the that's
Washington formerly football club
formerly oh they're not offensive
football club anymore no they they got a
name I mean football club like never
really made sense it sounds like
something from Ted lasso no it's like we
could all we're all football clubs right
why are you different um I don't like
the commanders commanders I don't like
it now it reminds me of fourth wi
commandment patch yes so they're playing
the Cowboys
oh and then the 49ers are playing the
Seahawks draft
day why draft day does that movie not
take place in Seattle no Cleveland of
course Cleveland of course sorry okay so
that's Thursday Thanksgiving Day then
Friday oh this is a very Jewish game
okay let me guess Jets vers Giants so
close Jets vers Dolphins yes that's like
the most Jewish game on the planet like
I can't explain it to you if you don't
get it Fins Up Fins Up I don't know if
that's it but it feels right the
Buccaneers versus the Colts feels
irrelevant oh the Patriots versus Giants
a Northeast battle the Steelers versus
the
Bengals and then there's like a million
games on Sunday I'm not going through
all these okay cool I feel like if oh
wait where are the Chiefs maybe they
have a byee oh no they're playing the
Vegas Raiders and the Eagles are playing
the bills I feel like that'll be a good
game a lot of people think those are
like the best teams in the east
coast it's not an East Coast oh yeah no
Zach was talking about Coast last night
in his diet dribe about the leagues
about the leagues right like I don't
think the leagues make sense
geographically because the 49ers and the
Eagles are in the same league yeah
they're on opposite Coast I don't even
want to say what I think it is because
I'm wrong say it like I think there's AF
based on I never thought this until he
tried to explain it to me last night I
think there's AFC and NFC and then
within those leagues there's like East
AFC East AFC West yes yes that's true
okay you're literally the meme right now
with the
math it shouldn't be this hard no it
shouldn't be this hard yet here we are
they just want to keep us down and
uneducated so true but they don't know
we're women in sports and we can't be
stopped no and we're going to keep
commenting on it as if we know it's more
fun that way honestly no that's
literally my life speaking on things
with absolute certainty that like I
really know nothing about though I just
think it's worth mentioning I wasn't
certain yesterday when I said this I I I
don't know you were being pretty adamant
like was I I feel like you're like no
tury it's a scrimmage oh but there was
something I wasn't un certain
about I can't even
remember um so that's your football
update sorry if your ears are bleeding
we can't be stopped no we seriously
can't be we're in our football eras you
guys I think we're going to try out for
the team no it brings us such Joy
honestly I could see us down the line
becoming like a family that plays flag
football on Thanksgiving that's like a
thing well yeah but we could do that
anyway no but like now I could see it as
a possibility yeah we could have done it
before but now I think like we actually
would or we should like go to a game as
a family would
love who would we go to we don't even
have a team oh I'm a like I'm a Jets
49ers fan like jets for my soul 49ers
for my Instagram okay so we would go to
a Jets game it depends am I visiting you
are you visiting me I would go to a
Dolphins game
yeah I just feel like the Dolphins need
a Rebrand like I'm not into their colors
it's so like ugly yeah I feel like ever
since Ventura they never really D Marino
yes they could never really achieve more
than that Jackie sometimes like we
literally have the same brain Dan Marino
Ace Ventura P detective detective that
movie is so good yeah that's one of the
movies that like I think when we talk
about like Mean Girls like we quot it so
much but I don't think we acknowledge
like the impact it had on us I mean
whoer is from Ace Ventura so true no
like that movie was impactful and like
what a random movie like if somebody
were to say like what's aent tet
detective about I would be like I don't
like I literally don't know I think
there was a a dolphin died in the went
missing went missing went missing also
I'm pretty sure that movie is like
cancelled in some circles and that it
didn't age well oh I haven't seen it in
a while why I'm going to botch it but
something about the storyline is like um
womane a man pretending to be a woman
and I think it's trans phobic who's
pretending to be a woman one of the
villains something you know what oh you
are right I know what you're talking
about I need to rewatch and I'll let you
know if it stands a test of time but I
sounds like it doesn't it's been branded
transphobic turty okay another one bites
the
dust um we've got a great show we've got
five stories correct I mean actually
it's funny that you ask cuz you never do
but we actually had six stories and I
was think think during the ad break I'll
Whittle them down but they've whittel
themselves because we already discussed
one of them oh the game the game okay
which is good because I had another
Travis story and like it's just becoming
the morning Kelsey over here so it
worked itself out as it always does let
me ask you a question are you feeling at
all fatigued in terms of I feel like
when we talk about a story a lot it gets
like kind of old at some point and it's
like there are more stories and you
don't know if you should choose them
because they're relevant but like we've
been talking about it non-stop do you
feel any sort of fatigue with the Kelsey
bowl tayor of it all to to me they're
two separate things like Kelsey Bowl I'm
still Juiced up over like we haven't
talked about the brethren in that long
and they're just hysterical and it's
just good good clean fun like I good
clean fun I support family so no not
fatigued on that the Taylor Travis
relationship I'm not fatigued but I just
need to be mindful of not making it a
story every single day and not doing
like small potatoes just big potatoes
the big stuff yeah yeah okay that's fair
so that's my my theory let me know if
it's working for you guys or you know
don't let me know I'll probably continue
to do the same thing so just letting you
know my phone is on just in case I get a
phone call so if you hear anything of
course we understand thank you do strong
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know and
the fast five stories that you need to
know are brought to you by kiwi Co
unwrap inspiration with Super Fun
Science Tech technology and art projects
for kids with kiwi Co with nine
different subscription offers for
different ages and subjects there's
something for every kid when you give
kiwi Co it's so much more than a box of
toys it's the gift of Discovery through
Hands-On experiences giving kids the
tools to learn about topics that they
love from dinosaurs to rocket ships is
the season for serious fun so kbo
delivers fun Hands-On projects that
inspire a lifelong love of learning kwio
projects spark creative confidence for
ongoing tinkering and experimentation
sure you can buy a robot but isn't it
way more fun to build your own and way
more timec consuming because one thing
I've learned about being around kids
like they need constant simulation and
that's what's great about kiwo it's like
an adventure it takes a long time feel
you buy a toy the kid is done with it in
10 seconds and they never want to see it
again but kiwo is a box of awesome in
every but in every box delivered monthly
when it arrives it'll be your kids's
favorite day of the month they're
something for kids of all ages from
infants and preschoolers to teens and
Beyond there's no commitment so you can
pause the subscription or cancel it at
any time and it's designed by a team of
Educators makers engineers and Rocket
scientists who brainstorm hundreds of
ideas to create the most exciting age
appropriate and educational projects
these are real engineering science and
art projects with high quality materials
and with you know the holidays coming up
you need a gift for each night of Kaneka
Ki makes a great gift Christmas all
Quanza all holidays discover Hands-On
fun with kiwi Co get your first month
free on any crate line at kiwico.com
toast that's your first month free at
kiwi.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by papaya okay Jax are you ready to
play a little game it's called queen or
wench ooh how fun yes I'm ready okay
first question is a friend that gives
you a pair of fuzzy socks for the
holidays a queen or a wench wench such a
gener gift next okay is a daughter that
gives her mom an offensively scented
candle for the holidays a queen or a
wench wench okay last one is someone who
gives you reusable paper towels from
papaya for the holidays a queen or a
wench oh that's easy she's a queen it's
giving giving eco-friendly it's giving
useful it's giving unique it's giving
aesthetically cute see this is why we're
sisters cuz I could not agree with you
more I'm sure you remember us talking
about papaya a few weeks ago a ton of
you guys bought your own reusable paper
towels after we spoke about them and of
course we'd love to see that but for
those of you who haven't hopped on the
papaya train yet listen up one papaya
paper towel replaces 17 rolls of
disposable paper towels Jackie and I
have both been converted we have them
hanging all around our house and you
will not catch us buying regular paper
towels anymore now since the holiday
season is upon us we want to get into y
papaya the cutest easiest gift for
Christmas Hanukkah Secret Santa you name
it first of all they have adorable
festive holiday designs and since papaya
was founded by a Jewish Queen they also
have a Hanukkah design it's a little
jelly donut and we're obsessed they also
just introduced their new reusable gift
bags which are very chic we might just
wear them out to dinner later plus they
have four hilarious holiday cards but
it's 2023 we're not going to CVS to buy
a bunch of tacky plastic gift bags and
we're not standing around reading a
million generic holiday cards until we
find the one that sucks the least with
Papaya's holiday bundle you get the gift
you get the bag and you get the card
bada bing bada boom you're done I
honestly can't think of a better gift
for your mom your mother-in-law your
friends your colleagues your hairdresser
your doorman you need to get someone a
gift get them papaya so go to papaya
reusables tocom right now and use code
toast for 30% off sitewide that's papaya
usabl.com code toast merry Christmas and
happy Hanukkah from
papaya thank you la you're
welcome our first
story is it sad no I was just reading
about the potential hostage deal I I
wanted to see if it went through but I
didn't I don't see anything sorry
sidetracked um I'm switching it up and
you know what I decided I want to talk
more about Taylor Travis and Mama Kelsey
because in his wide ranging interview
with the Wall Street Journal yesterday
and I saw this yesterday but like I've
just been rumin ruminating on it and I
want to talk about it Travis talked
about how his mom Donna regretted her
initial response to the awkward Taylor
Swift question so remember on The Today
Show yeah she did an interview and it
came off that like she was not feeling
Tor but she just didn't want to overstep
and she felt really bad about it so
Donna Kelsey still feels regret over her
answer when asked about her son Travis
Kelsey's relationship with Taylor Swift
during an interview last month the
Kelsey matriarch uh opened up to Wall
Street Journal magazine about her son's
budding romance with Taylor during her
sit-down interview on The Today Show in
October she seemingly came off
unenthusiastic about Swift when in
reality she simply didn't want to
overstep in oversharing once the
interview had aired Travis immediately
called his mom to assure her that she
did a good job after saying she SP
spending time with Taylor was quote okay
while she still looks back in regret
over her underwhelming answer Donna
didn't hold back her gushing over Taylor
now she said I can tell you this he's
happier than I've seen him in a long
time God bless him he shot for the Stars
like the story kind of makes me sick
like she's like you know lamenting over
this interview she shouldn't have been
asked that like she's not a media
trained celebrity she's just a mom and I
like feel bad that she's like sitting
stewing regretting thinking and like
when it happened she was probably
bugging like oh my God is Travis going
to be mad at me and I don't think Taylor
by any means I think Taylor's really
understanding of like how media works
and I don't think she would have thought
for a second that like Donna Kelsey went
on the Today Show to shade you know her
son's new boyfriend but like I I I
didn't need her to apologize or like
address this you know what like she did
what she had to do I was when I watched
it I didn't think for a second she was
being nasty I thought for sure she was
uncomfortable and she just didn't want
to overstep Taylor Who's like this
notoriously private person who's the
biggest star on the planet like please
Donna you're fine yeah but I understand
why she said just okay now I understand
why she feels regret cuz it came off
like oh I'm so not impressed with my new
potential daughter in-law when it's none
of those things right like I guess if
you watch it and you're like an alien
visiting for Mars you could be like oh
you know this person's dismissive right
but that's so not anyone with any sort
of like critical thinking ability would
know that this is much more layered than
that Donna and I'm pretty sure that's
what we said when we mentioned it like
it's not this speaking of things that
that are not this this isn't a story but
it's a perfect segue because Snoop Dog
announced that he's you know giving up
smoke and in his partnership with solo
stove he no longer has smoke in his life
but he is still smoking marijuana so it
was a very sort of elaborate partnership
I think it was brilliant honestly I love
solo stove a former toe sponsor come
back where have you guys been um and I
love the solo stove product and I
thought this was great like really
that's how you make waves it's so hard
these days like I feel like everybody's
so used to like seeing you know when
you're being targeted for some sort of
product like consumers are much like
savier than they used to be so it's hard
to really like pull one over and shock
people as a brand and I think that's
what's so exciting about the Super Bowl
is like everybody does the most and this
was kind of Super Bowl level yeah this I
I was actually thinking when I saw the
announcement I was like oh when's the
Super Bowl and I'm like oh no it's not
to do with it but it's something that
you would do like the week before the
Super Bowl and then the commercial y
during the Super Bowl so I love a brand
like doing the most and it's holiday
season Q4 very important time of year so
it was strategic it was very smart and I
enjoyed it and I think you know people
who thought about his announcement that
he was quitting smoke you know they
thought of it a little suspiciously and
they thought of it you know more
critically than others like ourselves um
they were right yeah I did see it in the
article that people were being doubters
I don't know if I would have come to
that conclusion on my own I didn't have
the opportunity right you're right like
everybody else when somebody said the
edible thing I was like yeah but I can't
say that I would have because I don't
know I didn't have the opportunity I
thought this was great like I really
they got us you know yeah I'm sure they
paid him a boatload of money to really
like for a few days put his brand up in
the air like that right like kind of
offer this sort of
questionable message yeah yeah no he
must have been paid a lot but it all
worked out that's like also another
brand publicity moment this week do you
see the Stanley thing with obsessed so a
woman her car was on fire I think she
got into some sort of like her car
literally blew up yeah like there's no
car left really to speak of but it's
ashes the Stanley that was in her cup
holes are remained intact and so not not
only that the ice inside the cup was
still in cubes it hadn't melted from the
fire that's insane and as if that's not
a good enough endorsement for Stanley
already like it will withstand all of
that the CEO of Stanley then bought her
a new car right so her video went
totally viral she's like you guys look
at my car it's like it literally was
black ashes like fog smoke and then she
pulled her Stanley out of the cup holder
like it was a little banged up it wasn't
perfect but it was perfectly intact and
then she shook it and there was ice in
there and everybody was like what the
video went so viral so then the CEO of
Stanley stitched it on Tik Tok and
responded being like this is amazing
this is such a testament to how our
products are made we so appreciate we're
so sorry we're obviously going to
replace your Stanley and we're also
going to replace a brand new car and it
was honestly like the best money
marketing could buy like now everybody
like feels you know warmly about Stanley
as a company like this girl lost her car
and they're doing the right thing and
going above and beyond by giving her a
new car her video was really highlighted
the the quality of of their cups I was
shook and now everybody just looks at
them favorably and they didn't have to
spend a lot of money this is like
billions of Impressions and they' just
spent the cost of a car yeah billions of
Impressions cuz I think I saw I didn't
see her initial video but I saw it as a
story because he was buying her a car
like brilliant brilliant like there are
ways to get creative when you're trying
to make waves that is the perfect segue
to our next story because our next story
is a little more Brands getting in on
the fun okay Chipotle renamed their
Kansas City location to honor Travis
Kel's 2011 misspelled tweet after the
hilarious post resurfaced Amit his
romance with Taylor Swift so in 2011
Travis Kelce tweeted went from class to
therapy now I need some # Chipotle and
then I'm off to check out my new
apartment so Kansas City's Chipotle
location rename themselves chipot like
renamed how like a new sign a new sign
wow well let me say I don't think
Travis's tweet was a typo a lot of
people who like who love Chipotle call
it Chipotle like it's like
T okay so it's like a thing people say
so I don't think it was a like mishap or
a mistake but that doesn't make this any
less funny and fun and also the official
Chipotle Twitter account did rename
themselves chipot at least for you know
the day for the time being and they
replied and said it's me hi
cute cute cute no it's fun like this is
where I feel like being the social media
manager of and social media managing is
like a job that's mostly women they're
young girls and I feel like it's a job
that people think is like irrelevant and
like they don't put respect on that name
they're like oh yeah Bob from Finance
you know but moments like this like you
really have an opportunity to make so
many so much news so many Impressions
and this is fabulous a win for the
social media managers yes but it is also
a fine line sometimes it's not all just
fun in games as a social media manager
as we have discussed you know you go out
drinking which account did you post to
Instagram the pope but also like
sometimes Brands try and get in on the
fun and then the the parties it's like
no it's really important that your
social media manager obviously
understand like how the world works but
also as an extremely self-aware person
yeah and self-aware on behalf of your
brand yes yeah it's a delicate balance
but this hits it out of the park a lot
of brands are really doing good stuff
this week congrats yeah congrats Brands
congrats Brands and then with the Super
Bowl coming up I mean Super Bowl is
always coming up no but like it's
actually coming up now it's like 3
months away for sure but now it's like
the holidays are coming up so like the
brands go hard yeah well that's actually
a great segue to our next sponsor which
is sprit Society having a major Black
Friday sale the Segways are on fire
today tury l so it's the biggest sale of
the Year Black Friday if you've been
waiting for spit Society to go on sale
launching tomorrow the entire site will
be 35% off plus I'm not done free
shipping and that includes all the new
flavors and the fan favorites like pink
lemonade and passion fruit in addition
to having their biggest sale ever
they're also launching two new bundles
that are 40% off for a limited time only
so the the lemonade stand which features
three to four three four packs of pink
lemonade and three four packs of lemon
the tropical Trio which features two
packs of four packs of passion fruit
Peach and pineapple are all 40% off so
the sale starts tomorrow Wednesday and
it runs all the way to Cyber Monday so
you have almost a full week to get in on
the amazing sale it's the perfect time
to stock up for all your giftgiving
needs if you're doing a white El
elephant or a secret santa also just
great to have Spritz on hand through the
holidays so this is a great time to
stock up you know the fridge and the
outdoor fridge don't miss out set your
alarms at 12:00 p.m. eastern time
tomorrow it's running all the way till
Cyber Monday 35% off sitewide and 40%
off your two new bundles if you've been
on the fence about ordering sprit
Society now is the time go to sprits
society.com that's sprit TZ society.com
the discount will be automatically
applied on the website no code needed
starts tomorrow don't miss out thank you
la you're welcome fa our next story is
more holiday shopping news cheermeister
the holiday cheermeister this year is
Jennifer lren as she laughed off a
wardrobe malfunction at the saxs Holiday
lighting ceremony Jennifer Lawrence
handled a wardrobe malfunction like a
pro during the sax Fifth Avenue holiday
lighting ceremony on Monday night I
don't know if it was like a pro but it
did play very well no it was cute and
funny but like it wasn't subtle no it
wasn't subtle the Oscar winner was
giving a speech before unveiling the
department store and dior's Carousel of
Dreams 2023 holiday window displays when
her belt unexpectedly popped off and
fell to the ground it didn't
unexpectedly pop off she goes up to the
microphone and she starts to talk and
the microphone is so much louder than
she anticipated that the sound of her
voice scared the [__] out of her so she
like jumped back and her belt popped off
got it oh right so then she said I'm so
sorry that was so loud my that was so
loud my belt popped off yeah when I saw
the video I thought she was saying her
belt popping off was loud no no no the
microphone scared her which is such a
tury move like the sound of your own
voice scaring you never for you no no
yes for me I'm not talking about my
singing voice I'm talking like I could
literally be talking I be like oh my God
and it was just like my voice scared me
you being scared by things yeah yeah
even if it's something that I'm doing
like talking got it for sure yeah
anyways um she looked gorgeous oh my God
she looked gorgeous like I'm looking at
the pictures of her up there and it's
like is it the lighting or is it her I
mean I guess everyone looks like it's
her they also look nice the other
presenters but she looks unreal no she
looks sick I believe she's some like
Ambassador or face of Dior which is why
she was selected for this partnership
yeah she has been a Dior Ambassador
since 2012 also I'm pretty sure it was a
Dior belt so that's really not a great
advertisement like your Bells should
stay on even when the microphone's loud
yikes so true but how do you balance
that with us now talking about the saxs
Dior event even though we never would
have talked about that before even if
she was there and everything went
smoothly ever so true so many
Impressions now that the toast is
talking about it and it'll make up for
the loss of belt sales right I think net
net this is a good thing if I was a
social media manager I would say don't
worry guys it's good and what would you
tweet about the
belt back to the factory to tighten up
those seams someone's getting fired no
like I would literally like go to like
where they make belts I don't know do
you make it in like a factory or like a
a aier yeah aier and I would interview
like one of the seamstresses and she
would be telling us what she's you know
re reconfiguring so that the belt you
buy this holiday season won't snap off
or maybe it's like interviewing the
seamstress and getting to know her story
and maybe yeah maybe a seam was skipped
but it's because she's been going
through something no and then it turns
into an episode of Undercover Boss like
they buy her a new house and a new car
and a Stanley okay funny first of all
second of all I love that like we are
now in the time of year like the
department stores are doing their thing
and and even though New York becomes
like a torture chamber during the
holiday season because everybody flocks
here to shop to see the Big Trees the
big Christmas lights at sex it's
undeniably magical and this is exciting
this is like the official you know start
yeah yeah right before Thanksgiving so
exciting I actually just printed my
recipes I've got to do my holiday shop
it's yep it's starting yeah know when I
walked home from work yesterday this
building I pass every day to from to and
from work had their big Christmas tree
they're like a big office building that
like has a kind of an iconic tree um and
I actually was having such a bad day
yesterday especially after the toast
like I just I had nothing left to give
in that tree like Christmas joy and
Christmas spirit like is real it's real
the holiday cheer Master is real yeah so
thank you Jennifer Lawrence cuz I
probably wouldn't have even like known
or cared that like the sax thing lit up
last night but okay let's play a fun
game how would you rank like the major
department stores in New York their
window displays and um the stores are
include Sachs bergdorf's Bloomingdales
Macy's Bloomingdales is really
bad wow you think so yeah I I don't know
what their holiday is this year but like
that's probably the store that I
frequent the most and their Windows do
nothing they they don't inspire me to
buy anything it's they're not really on
the same level as like saxs or bergd
dorfs at all I think bergd dorfs is
number one that's their thing but I
think everybody else is stepping their
[__] up like sax saaks honestly sax is
a really really close second I I'll have
to see the ones this year to make my
decision but you're right like Bergdorf
if you ever saw the documentary scatter
my ashes at burgdorf like they talk
about the window displays they're
they're like year round projects they
have artists from all over the world
working on it for years and years like
it's amazing yeah so they have the
number one spot but I think people are
coming for their neck yeah Macy's is
like a lot I think it's like a little
tacky what's great about Sachs and Berg
dorfs is like it's opulent but it's very
tasteful and like tailored saxs I mean
Macy's is just like lights [__] trees
like it's so much but that's also the
holiday sometimes it's a little too tast
a little too tailored whereas where's
the nuttiness where's the holiday nut
while Macy's doesn't have the holiday
Windows like on lock they do have the
Thanksgiving Day Parade which is one of
my favorite things of all time even
though like the older I get the more I
realize like it's dumb and fake but I
love it it's so fake but then but then
when you have kids like the love comes
back and you start again the magic let
us see who's in the parade this year
what we can look forward to
yeah um P performances and more okay
here's the parade for yeah we know it's
literally the same every year thanks oh
my gosh get to the I feel like the
parade is like very last minute like
whoever's available but it is last
minute now it's two days away the parade
will be kicked off by
multi-instrumentalist and Grammy winner
John batist there will be performances
by a bunch of people I'm going to read
the people that we know David Foster and
Katherine MC yeah they have a holiday
album out Jesse James Decker okay
pregnant
Queen Ashley Park with some Muppets oo
close your ears
pentatonics okay I will say the only
time it's acceptable to embrace
pentatonics is the holiday season so
I'll allow it and that song that you
introduced me to oh my god there can be
Miracles their version honestly this
might be the craziest thing I've ever
said like is as good is Mariah and
Whitney like it's really good it's so
good also this is newsworthy for a
reason Broadway will be represented by
performances from an Juliet back to the
future of the musical how to dance in
Ohio shucked and spam a lot will
SpongeBob be there Ethan Slater oh my
God maybe Ari will be at the event or
maybe she'll be in like a penthouse on
Columbus Avenue on the upper W side like
watching from above 100% like in a big
blanket yeah and this year's Santa will
be accompanied on his sleigh by The One
and Only
share who's preparing she's preparing to
release a 25th anniversary edition of
her gramming winning album Believe and
she just dropped her new album Christmas
that's a big get for the parade I feel
like the talent over the last couple of
years is definitely less premium than it
used to be this is shar's Major this
isn't a great lineup no it's not it's
usually like a little better and they
usually have a lot of like pretty big
country people cuz it's really like a a
parade that the whole country watches
yeah like where's Gavin gr honestly
where the [__] is
Kelly where the [__] but Kelly's at a
place in life H where she doesn't have
to do things like this but let me just
say something she has nestled her way
into the hearts of millions of Americans
and on Thanksgiving morning we want to
see you like that's the there's
responsibility that's here's the
responsibility that's the price that you
pay for being such a joyful part of our
lives like we want to see you on these
big joyful occasions yes I will say
though I think as a if you're a
performer I think once you get to a
certain level like the Thanksgiving Day
Parade is probably like the worst gig on
the planet you don't sing live you're
[__] freezing you're standing out
there forever it's the crack of dawn and
it's a holiday so if you don't live in
New York you're away from your family no
I know but I think there are some people
who have a duty who have a
duty to show up for us on those days
yeah it's not always fun in games being
America's sweetheart it's not it's hard
work someone's got to do it and Kelly's
not doing it no so but honestly like
there should be a few bigger names here
sorry I am in agreement like like also a
little bit more relevant peeps I also
feel like if Macy's doesn't step it up
like someone's going to come out from
under them like the Netflix Day parade
and all of a sudden like be Finn is
flying through the air I'm really glad
you brought that up because it does feel
like Macy's is hanging on to that
partnership by the hair of their chinny
chin chin it's been their thing for so
long and I'm not against them being the
sponsor it's so New York it's so classic
I think it nods you know to a more
simpler time but I agree like the parade
has severely gotten worse in terms of
everything like production some of those
[__] balloons have been around since
the 80s and like it's okay like they're
not relevant to the kids anymore like
Clifford can go it's my mom's from the
80s yeah
literally like they need to step their
[__] up majorly and they need to get
like a streaming partner like why why
doesn't it stream on peacock you know
like it needs to be a little bit more
21st century just saying it might stream
on peacock it definitely does but like
that's how irrelevant it is I didn't
even know that no no no like I'm I'm
just saying like it's on NBC right yeah
so like it definitely goes to Peacock
after oh no I'm sorry it's on like a
bunch of
networks NBC
syndicates no I feel like it's also
because I remember Kelty did oh yeah
like everybody films the parade I guess
right Macy's like doesn't really do it
with one right because I think Kel was
on CBS I remember that
it's
I we'll find out on Thursday I mean I
feel like also for for the parents here
are the kid balloons that are coming
through recurrent giant balloons include
Bluey Diary of a Wimpy Kid Paw Patrol
Ryan's World Pikachu Ronald McDonald
Ronald McDonald for real like Pikachu
steuart the minion and SpongeBob
SquarePants oh he's doing double
duty he's booked he's booked and busy
wait and then new balloons beagle Scout
Snoopy blue cout and chugs Kung Fu Panda
Po Leo monkey deffy Pillsbury Doughboy
yum and Uncle Dan they'll also be Lego
peanuts baby shark Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and Sesame Street where the [__]
is Mickey Harry's not going to be happy
about this Mickey where is Mickey Misa
Musa Mickey Mouse I don't
know hot
dog
hot
dog hot dog hot dog hot diggity dog that
song [__] slaps that song goes so
hard and has business doing so if I ever
become like a true well-respected
vocalist I will perform at the parade I
will be on the
mecky float I will bring Harry and I
will sing that song but like my I'll put
my own spin on it more of like an
acoustic you know I'll have like
accompanying guitar there's a long
version of it on Spotify like it goes
into this grab my boots and a sandwich
let's start a parade it's get the
coconut charm kid I'm ready to
play It Go Claudia like these songs they
go crazy but okay I don't know if this
is an insult to you but it's not meant
to be oh I love sentences that start
that way but it's not meant to be okay
you should be performing at the aming
Thanksgiving Day Parade okay that's is
an insult but I don't disagree also if
you're an adult watching my favorite
game to play is like catch the
lipsyncing flubs because because they
also have like guitar they have like if
they're a band they have their
instruments if they're not a band they
still have like a backup pianist and
nothing is live not the piano not the
guitar not the music not the track not
the singing and they never know like
when to properly start my favorite thing
is catching them like [__] up they're
it's so easy too it's literally like No
And like a few years ago it came out
that every nobody performs live on the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade and so
they don't have to pretend anymore yeah
and they've given up The Jig Is Up The
Jig is officially up oh Jaxon is taking
a break why don't you Grace everyone
with a song while I blow my
nose it's m is a fun time song Hot do
God
hot
hotg someone turned the air on like in
the middle of the show in here and it's
just so cold my nose is running I also
just remembered that I drove to work
because it was so [__] cold and it
was like the worst mistake ever there
was so much traffic it would have been
so much faster to walk and I parked
illegally like I know my car is going to
be towed when I go outside like I just
know it how fun for Ben to pick it up
today yeah CL we clears this
afternoon um okay it feels like the end
of the show but we still have two more
stories oh my God I know our next story
someone who will never perform at the
Thanksgiving D Day Parade I feel like I
can say with confidence wait let me
think let me think let me think are they
a singer
yeah I don't know
Adele oh facts facts Adele appears to
confirm she and Rich Paul are officially
married oh Adele reportedly confirmed
that she and Rich Paul tied the kn the
six-time Grammy winner is said to have
shared the news at her longtime friend
Alan Carr's comedy gig in LA on Saturday
two members of the audience recounted
Adele's purported admission to celebrity
gossip Instagram account dumois they
said I was at Alan car's comedy show in
LA tonight and Adele was in the audience
Allan asked the crowd if anyone got
married recently and Adele shouted I did
another attendee told Duma when he asked
if anyone got married recently sheeld I
did super cute all around and was super
sweet but dipped right before it ended
um I feel like this would be on brand I
think like her and Rich Paul are like
even if they're not legally married like
they're they're in a like they're legit
you know they're steady and her doing it
like totally privately is so Adele like
giving us nothing I know but I'm happy
for her like I guess it is Adele and it
isn't cuz she's like actually public
with her relationship right now I feel
like they just didn't have a big wedding
maybe while she was in Vegas they were
like what certain things like Adele
doesn't [__] around with and like she
never shows her son like she's very very
she's like a she's a girly and she chats
and she loves you know to go out with
the girls but when it comes like her
family and her actual private life like
she really doesn't share much yeah
that's true we didn't even know her
son's name for like five years remember
and what is his name Antonio something
like that yeah right so I actually this
is like if true extremely on brand I
could see it being true yeah and and
lovely and I I I feel like whether or
not they got married like they will B
together for a very long time if not
forever like marriage it's all the same
it's all the same and like it's nice to
for her to go into this marriage like
you know she had to give half what'd she
give her ex guy $70 million she did yeah
it was like one of those crazy things
but this is a person who is extremely
successful not on the same level as
Adele but like up there and you know
she's going into this now with the
knowledge from her first she's probably
much more protected yeah and so I feel
good about this yeah and cuz I feel like
people who go through really bad
divorces they like don't they stop
believing in marriage and like love even
and they're just be they become so like
hard yeah but she's been softened no but
like if anything you go into the next
one with so much more experience and
knowledge and like you know what to do
what you did right what you did wrong so
I feel like second marriages are can can
be fabulous yeah another chance at
love speaking of Love Are you ready for
our fifth and final Story the Segway are
just writing themselves this afternoon
they literally are speaking of Love and
Marriage first comes love then comes
marriage then comes a baby in the baby
carriage let me think who's
pregnant who for Bliss and Zach of Love
is
Blind yeah love is blind Bliss is
pregnant expecting her first I feel like
for them it wasn't first comes love then
comes marriage I feel like it was first
comes marriage then comes love like
first comes Irena then comes marriage
then then comes love then comes baby in
the baby carriage and I feel like when
they did that love is blind reunion they
talked about they were at a fertility
doctor like they were struggling a
little bit yeah and they were showing us
the journey so they've been wanting to
start a family and now they are sharing
that they are having a baby the couple
um did an exclusive People magazine
interview and photo shoot Bliss said
it's a little bit nerve-wracking but I
think it's also such a beautiful thing
babies are Miracles and blessings and I
think we've been so open to sharing our
journey and our relationship with the
world and this is our next big beautiful
thing I'm really happy and I hope hope
that it brings joy to other people it's
definitely brought us a ton of Joy
that's really nice like they for
me are so Random like I I just I yeah I
know you were when we were watching it
like I did not believe in these people's
loves like I just I couldn't see how how
this could be real but like we always
say there is proof in the pudding
there's proof in the longevity they're
having a child now is this the first
Love is Blind
baby because Amber and Barnett don't
have kids that's a very good point uh I
don't think Lauren and C Cameron
Hamilton speed
don't I feel like People magazine would
have noted
that and there you know you know Bart
what was his name Bart no um barti yeah
I mean he had like a baby but not with
someone from the show yeah and so did uh
Mark who was 24 and Jessica was 34 like
he had a baby too so people have had
babies but not couples who got married
on the show yeah no there's a big
difference like I feel like this is the
first one I think so too first that
comes to mind for me
right good call so from their season
they're still going strong and so are
Chelsea and kwami yeah is that it I feel
like there was another strong couple
from their
season all the season's really like
mixed together I'll have to ask Zach
because he's a love as blind expert
he'll be so happy to hear about this no
it's actually really sweet like I should
text him it I'll text him the news
you're right like when we always say
like couples who are like really meant
to be like start to look alike and I
actually think these two look alike when
I saw the picture of them holding the
bump I'm like oh
siblings that's so funny like if your if
your baby announcement doesn't look like
two cousins having a baby like it's not
going to last you know what I've
realized well one when people date they
start to look like one another when they
get married and everything but when you
have a child and usually the child looks
like a bit of each of you it's like the
husband looks like the kid and the kid
looks like the the mom therefore the dad
and the mom look alike like if a equals
b and b equals c then a equals c yeah
but a doesn't equal C but I appreciate
the logic no I'm telling you start to
think start you'll see a equals
c a equals
c and what is b equal a and C that's the
point thank you for asking that question
that was like the one thing we learned
in math class like I actually understood
a equals b and b equals c so like duh a
equals c you know that's literally what
I'm saying yeah I know I'm not talking
about like your dumb theory about the
kids I'm talking about like math yeah
Chain Reaction Chain Reaction right
remember when we learned like logic and
math that [__] was so dumb right but
look we're literally we use it in
everyday life even 1 plus one equals
sock they didn't teach us that in school
but it's the
same think
no we could do like a college course on
1 plus one equals sock like a like a
mini mini call sock
101 we
could so those were actually very good
stories I feel like we all in all
covered like eight stories because there
were breakout sessions from each of them
there were and we love to Foster
breakout sessions in our work and that's
what you'll get in sock 101 that is I
will say like that part of college like
the big lectures and then like the
breakout sessions what do they call it
recitation that was like some of my
least favorite [__] of all time those
Tas thought they were such [__] hot
[__] I'm like calm down yeah Tas man did
it ever
um was that ever something you wanted to
do like as a as an undergrad no because
as a dumb [__] I wasn't qualified but
so are ta's grad students or undergrad
students no they're undergrad students
who I guess have excelled in the
course paid to be a TA question mark I
believe believe so question as you
[__] should you do all the work for
that dumbass
Professor yeah I've never was struck so
much by my ta experience no I was I was
like you're a nerd get away from me but
also like isn't there a uh a storyline
and Gossip Girl once they get to College
like Serena [__] one of the Tas I think
he's a full-blown Professor but yeah oh
okay cuz like [__] a TA is like
literally it's like [__] a classmate
it's like not a big deal no of course
also no we put Tas like on a
pedestal no literally you do no I think
everyone does okay first of all I never
really thought twice about my Tas maybe
it's different at every school but can
someone explain like ta are undergrads
like I didn't say that with certainty
now I'm just doubting everything and so
are
Aras yeah I only say they're undergrads
because we didn't have a grad school at
Colgate so if we had Tas they were
students oh NYU was like a grad school a
law school it's confusing but I do
believe that just maybe every school is
different maybe but I I am sorry to the
TA who hurt you clearly no I honestly
just like remember what I just remember
thinking I'm like you're a loser like
you like he just really he was on a
[__] power trip I'm like calm the
[__] down down calm down yeah he just
thought he was such hot [__] like he was
like a decently looking person and I
think he just like loved being like a
teacher he loved the TA life yeah and
like back then like you like you
respected Authority and now in hset I'm
like you're literally 2 years older than
me sit the [__] down [__] yeah he was
your wing leader
yes yes it's giving uh
Doos datos datos it's giving datos
datos so that's our show it's our final
one of the week but don't fret because
if you're really missing us Wednesday
Thursday Friday we will have podcast
episodes going up on patreon tomorrow's
patreon episode is the fast five stories
you need to go know for the Thanksgiving
table so we'll be coming through the
news breaking it down for you you know
with as much certainty as we can and
also giving you a hot take to bring to
the table and kind of like stir [__] up
start stuff why not what if we just
started stuff what if we just burn this
[__] dinner to the ground but the
Stanley would stay
standing um so that's our show and
that's how you bring It full circle in
sock 101 we'll see you on patreon also
make sure to head over to shopto
merch.com to get your holiday wenas sets
hope everybody has an amazing
Thanksgiving um I'm thankful for you JX
I'm thankful for you turd I'm thankful
for the toast and The Toasters who tune
in every day and just love to giggle
with us I love you all do strong prayers
for Theo please keep him in your
thoughts and prayers Theo is
non-denominational so he will accept
prayers from all religions he loves all
and yeah do strong love you thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
to podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so that's Spotify public video radi cast
box all the plac listen podcast to leave
a five star about a beautiful standing
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing holiday weekend we
love you and we're back in studio on
Monday love you
bye